par
ぽい落石注意という看板がありましてやっぱり人があまりここに入ってこないん
でしょうね
そうですねいった意味でをトレーがねここに出る着やすいんじゃないかなというふうに
思いますけれどムーン
まずはこのトンネルに着く前白石注意
いろいろサティ
十分注意していただきたいと思いますはいありがとうござ翔さんどうですかいまー
いやーはまずはこれ安全運転を心がけていただきたいなというふうに思います彼らの
右側にはガード頭大丈夫ですよ
キューバをかけてちゃんがさあそうです何かを見つけますがいいかチェック
びっくりしましたよ私はん
やはりこのへ細いもう道がどんどん富山市になって育っていくと右側やガードレール
あるんですけど左側には大きいが美味しいれていてその中にはあった気があるのかどう
かちょっと
よるまあ光量足りないられた確認できない部分はありますけども
そこの頭を向けまして完全に青いチハ
いましたまあこの3時やこういう感じじゃ非常に嫌な感じなってきましたよ
担当なんじゃねーか話か別男子会や風邪なにネズミちの子
つちのこせき700が飛んできましたよじゃうわぁわぁわあきれいすごくないですけど
今先生すごい抹茶って怖い怖い怖い怖いなにこれ
92ちゃーん伝わります運よくすぐ後ろ譲って伝わんないよこれヌード行きディッシュ
まばゆい光みたいな映像になっちゃうかもしれないな
[音楽]
アナウンサーと心霊スポット行ってみたらどうなるなぁ
今日肇社長等柴田ですアナウンサーですよね所長あざーすちょんニャーあれ
クラーン天気がすごいマティスちょんちょんっ
陥った桜
ハプニングが起きると普段の僕だったっていう友達と行くてなが李根在シーンが多い
ですがやっぱりすると
なんですけども黙り込んだりする強させらもうほと細かくその状況説明していただける
と
そうなったら怖くないんじゃないかなと思いまして
ございましたねかかってるわけですね今みたいにドンってなった時もそのものを問うだ
よと彼はそれ
実況していただけると心霊スポットをたまっていけるんじゃないかなと思いますもう
我々の舞見えてますけど嫌な勉強ありますねちこいねっ夏と4パターンの歌の実況力を
信じてね
外行ってみたいと思いましたよろしくお願いします今からどこに行くべもうあれはの目
の前に見えている
q 本坂トンネルとああいう場所なんですけども静岡県と愛知県の県境に位置をしてい
まして
一番いい有名なあー心霊現象っっ
逆さ音だ
高さ女廃トンネルの天井に座れのもう目の前に見えてばっかでされる
ですねあの天井にですね逆さになった女性が現れましてはうようにして追いかけてくる
そう
その他ですねまぁ老婆俺の女性
行った着物姿の女性実は小さな赤ん坊を抱いた女性などさまざまな女性の幽霊が出て
くるという話があるそうです
なるほどこのちょっ如意棒まざーず系の揺れが出るぽされそうですね
えっ江戸時代に多くの
旅人がですね御坂道化というアバターなんですこのあたりこの本だがタグだと
を越えようとしたことに由来するという
5東海道にですね設けられていった
大丈夫座っても大丈夫ですねこの後に関所
新居関所という場所があるんですが女性の2区を厳しく
制限していたということで女性の旅人はですね
本坂峠の方までこのあたりまでお迎えして
まあ
移動していた旅をしていたとその峠越えのためになんと
命を落とした女性を買ったという逸話も残っておりますそれが強いという事でば女性の
例が多く見られると
んですさん何かあるんですか
1回もですねまあいろんな諸説
ですが大丈夫ですかあ作用でテレンス東名高速のウィトンネルで起きたバスも横転事故
などの幽霊が出ると
いう話だったりいうか本年の上の6エンドどけの墓の0
まあそういうのがあるんですよね web つ
もう墓ので9御坂隧道が心霊早期言われる理由というのは小説
ある
ことでございます金成その力チがあるといいますかそうなんで行えるというトンネルと
いうかいいえ
沢山の底ありがとうございますはいわれここについての必須でに何か1台
車が通ってるようなとだったねほんとに山道の中を抜けてここまで来たんですけれども
に来るまでは
一善見なかった中でトンロングに来るもう一度いたんですよねじゃあ絶対やらフェイス
よああそうですか
もう夏休みテーション入っちゃってやりゃ上がっちゃいましたねこれはさぁさぁ
それはですね有力のトンネルの中がどうなっているのかというところで
私とた13でハイ見に行こうと思います
食べましょうん
アーサーがきましたね
夕闇だねされ毛質未来にとってから2匹はるって pa に向かっていると
はいりょう機を流れる以外このトンネルまあドレスをたことしては
ブーヴィエない池田いいのかーチョッちゃんぬうっとしてそっちがわにはえーっ
ご覧ください ok 事はではね
ブーブチョンドンに行きまーぬーん
英語の
レンズも風が吹き込んでくるとそういう状況の中でですねー
が一生続く
言うとえ
声も環境してくるというような話
風すごいし
乗らず書がな掛け合わせ
そうかねはいありがとう病気だという
8違ったんです
今さあしておりますご結婚だったんですかこれは後ですよねそうですね
あなたは後結果をホテルでございますおめでとうございますこういう
マジな感じのオフィスと道ですがちょうどはまりびっくりしましたがうちらがカードの
反対側にはかなりを恋愛的なね
エアーいう外がある中でこちらには平和の裏には危険があるそして
目でぱんって心デビュー教訓的なねー
言われている
リストラ後ようにはありました
ちょちょーさんていましたアンカーでなんか半端ですね
いよいよですねこのいる白ゾーンをかなり向こうが思う
ああああああ
自分発泡真っ暗な状況という中でですね楽ナビゾーンというの
負け抜けましたそうだまあそれをもワードございかけているのか練習で戦うばそっちせ
ないと思います豊橋のヤリチンって入っての忘れや本を書いています
絶対だろうか仲裁を検出
あのうざいかける物始まりましたことで入っ
マイ口からからやるべきなんですけれども50m 位ですかねえええ
小澤さんに pt 影ですがあるからここまで来ていやーやったぁー
毎回心霊スポット毎年来てるんですけども強いね行ってきてもこういうタイプのやつだ
北洲ベースのピックするキャラになんですねちょっとさせたに僕も大きれないかな公務
回墓には山々柴田さんがいる限られますか
5をですが冗談素が良かったですなら気ないんですかじゃなぐらい本当にブロックまで
いきます
いやーちゃま良いところですけどペッパー各きたのであれば行きたいですねやはり
使っ
このここに来てです中盤にきて働きないけれども
さが引いてきたんあと一
延長ありますさらにちょっとトンネルのファイルから何時までですか
高さちょっと何買う
狭かった
2人イーズ尾根幕内板進めた時と変わったねこのアーチの構造
うざいが変わった気がしますねコズモこのうち海パンそろそろ出口が見えてきたと
な形になります
うわぁ直すと俺が最強と
かっこいいですね声なんでここでそれからは書こうと思った
じゃあこれけっこう最近というそうですね国際級ぽいですね
しか語ってるのかだは最近ですからですちょっと思われ
ちょっとレアな技術でちょこ示した
まあこれ顔と体とヘルプというをにされでは
ひょっこり小さい人が顔を覗い困っているような
これがかかる
それぞれ
には色はだいぶ変わりますねー
大丈夫ですかっね大3
本当に落下木の秒後まただから出口に向こう側から窓口に来て落書きをしていると
いう方が多いですよね報道を集めるでまあこれが出口に近づいてきている証拠ではある
ということで
からいもはトンネル内
c 版もれる今日はそこまでと
うわぁ当たる何ごぼうだからそれをね打つ
気になってるんですよねからそれもうちょっと続くじゃないですよ
違う大丈夫ジャイ絶叫止めましょう
それに抜かなきゃだと思います
さっすがにんですよねすごい会社さ
4つかせん spyair hey
んん
[音楽]
ブーブー do
ああああああああ
座ってあぁん
立っがぁああ
はぁ
はいという上座はいアナウンサーと一緒に心霊スポットに切ったら僕に幽霊がいる
ドッキリでした
yeah
ran
ぶーぶーっ
素晴らしい瞬発力でしまった武士団に切っておりましたので機械器具だと彼らろ
信じたじゃなかったと思う
me
これマジです30分くらいになってましたはぁはぁ